Cherokee towns were connected by trails
Native Americans whole lifestyle
depended on travel and when these trails
were destroyed they were cut off from
places that were sacred to him for years
and years I want to see these places
preserved I want to feel what the
Cherokees felt when they walked these
trails this great big story is inspired
by Genesis
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Lavar marshall cherokee call
me nano he D what s ki trail founder
spent the last 12 years mapping Indian
trails across the Appalachians I felt
compelled to quit my job in corporate
America and award full time to protect
the last Native American cultural sites
their history was taken away from him
and I was able to work with the Cherokee
and we bring in these records back to
the Cherokee people so that they can
teach their children and carry on their
culture and their traditions so what
we've done here is taken the oldest
historic maps in existence and use that
information and brought it forward to
the next generation of maps to early
surveys to say 1800 and then we have
reap allotted and defined exactly where
the Cherokee trails were and use this
information to produce the most modern
maps these trails represent a
significant part of the Cherokee
cultural heritage the Cherokees were
master travelers but white settlers came
in with their guns took their land and
the Cherokees were eventually expelled
all together
as I started mapping these trails I've
totaled up over a thousand mouths that
have mapped and I've walked over 200
miles of trails
[Music]
when I find work turkey trail should be
I'm looking for an impression in the
earth and I've actually come across
ancient petroglyphs carved into rock and
also some what we believe are twelve
marker trees that were bent by Cherokees
that marked certain trails lamar's
project is without a doubt one of the
most special and important pieces of
work that I've ever come across
bringing us here and showing us a real
piece of the trail where they walked is
very moving and it's so important to the
Cherokee tribes to remember this it's
important to me that I get to stand on
the place where my people were removed
at one time and I'm proud to be Church
[Music]
all the archives and all of the maps
that I produce all the records have gone
to the tribal Historic Preservation
Office so that they'll be accessible to
Cherokee people that can research their
family genealogies there's a lot more to
be discovered and we need to preserve
this so the culture of the Cherokee is
going to survive it's got to live own in
the minds and the hearts of the Cherokee
children and their youth
[Music]
[Music]